[Music]
everybody enjoyed the keynote earlier
was it good comes up cool nice didn't
get to see it myself but I watch it
tonight and keynote like all of the
sessions are also going to be available
on YouTube or trying to do the sessions
to be same-day so if you miss any
sessions today and thank you for coming
to this one and if you're missing any of
the others that are coming on at this
time you'll be able to watch them
tonight on YouTube so I'm gonna be
speaking about the power of geolocation
and speaking about how here in Google we
think about how location works how
places work and how everything in the in
the geosphere actually works and then
I'm gonna be drilling in onto something
called the Google Maps geolocation API
and this API is something that will
allow you to determine your location as
a latitude and a longitude without using
GPS so as a gratuitous demo I've built a
little robot here his name is Freddie
and Freddie's a little autonomous
self-driving robot that's you know have
had him driving around different
locations in San Francisco on I'm gonna
have him driving around the stage and
what he does is he uses the geolocation
API by sniffing cell tower signals
sniffing Wi-Fi signals that kind of
thing to get a location out of it
they'll talk a little bit about how the
data of location and the data that you
get from location sensors such as
Freddie has turned into intelligence and
we'll look at some customers and some
like innovative things that they've done
like this little device which is called
a pod and this is for pet tracking and
because it doesn't have GPS and it's
small enough to fit like I have a dog
who's not much bigger than Freddie here
and it's small enough to fit on his
collar so that I could geo locate my dog
so when you start opening up scenarios
beyond GPS and some of the things that
you can do like pet tracking and some
other stuff we'll take a look at that's
really innovative and really fun and
then some complementary services from
the Google geo API is from the Maps API
as well as from cloud and how you can
start thinking about how you can use
your geo data to really build
intelligence into your business but
first of all let's think about how the
world is organized and how the world is
organized from a geographic perspective
any location on the planet be in the
middle of the desert or the middle of
the ocean is the location and that
location can be measured by a set of
cool
ordinates the most common of which are
latitude and longitude and latitude and
longitude coordinates can be sensed
typically by a GPS but as I'll be
talking about in this session if you
don't have access to a GPS you can also
sense them in new and innovative ways
such as using Wi-Fi towers using beacons
sorry using cellular towers using
beacons and using Wi-Fi and we'll talk a
little bit about the API is that are
available for that but then beyond just
a location that has a latitude and a
longitude particularly when civilization
comes to a place you have addresses and
in maps we have an address API we have a
set of tools for addresses so that you
can get your addresses right so
autocomplete makes for a really nice
user experience think about if you're
building an app on you're trying to type
an address on a tiny little phone or
you're trying to do an aware that you
know addresses they're very very
different in different countries anchor
and I have a session later on today
we'll be going into a lot more detail on
that but some of the things that are
available in the Geo API is to make if
you're building applications to make
managing addresses a lot more easy then
on top of that you've got places so a
place is like a point of interest and in
Google we have over a hundred million
places stored in a database and there's
a a identifier for those places which
then allows you to get metadata for that
place so for example each floor in this
Convention Center is a place so and each
of those has a as that as a primary key
called the place ID that allows you to
access metadata about that place for
example opening hours photos things like
that if the place is a restaurants you
know it's you could get a menu you could
get photos you could get reviews that
people have done when they've gone into
that restaurant and as my mic gun out
with the places API as well you also get
the ability to detect the place that
you're in and this is more than just
like looking up a latitude and a
longitude and saying that you're in a
particular point of interest it has a
lot of intelligence behind it so for
example the scenario I always like to
think about is if I'm standing in the
middle of a street and there's a bus
stop five meters that way and there's a
coffee shop five meters that way
where am I am I at the bus stop or I'm a
at the coffee shop well what if the
coffee shop closes at 2:00 p.m. and I'm
there at 3 p.m.
then it's not likely I'm in the coffee
shop it's more likely I'm at the bus
stop that kind of intelligence with all
the places is made available to you as a
developer and with that kind of
intelligence you can start building and
empowering a lot of new scenarios and at
four o'clock today we'll be going into a
lot more detail on that as a session
call it's a location intelligent and
we'll be going into that in a lot of
detail there and having a bit of fun
with it too but I'm gonna focus in this
session on geolocation and how you can
do geolocation now why would you want to
geolocate
now there's a number of reasons why
number one it's most common to think in
terms of GPS but what if GPS isn't
available there are reasons why it may
not be available like if you're in a big
city and there are a lot of skyscrapers
in that city you may not get a clear
line of sight so the satellites to be
able to do geo GPS location or sensors
for Wi-Fi and for cell tower like I say
for something this small can be built
get cheaper and cheaper and you know GPS
unfortunately there are a larger circuit
and more expensive both in battery and
costs you know to build that you now
have new options where you can determine
a location of something so I can put
something like this on my pet and then
from my pet I can determine his location
if he ever gets lost
cuz it would be heartbreaking if you
ever lose your little doggie so these
are some of the reasons why you'd want
to locate and when you think about asset
measurement enterprises the asset manage
asset management industry it's growing
to about five billion dollar industry in
the next five years and how do we do
asset management at the moment it's
typically we put a barcode on every
device and we scan it in and we scan it
out but we don't actually know where the
device is located so cheap circuits this
guy is built on a first-generation
wrapper II Pi which was great because of
art but the newest Raspberry Pi one just
came out last week which is the size of
a stick of gum and it has a built in
Wi-Fi circuit and it cost 10 bucks I
actually ordered one so that I could do
it for this conference but it didn't
arrive on time so I'm stuck with the
older generation one that's it has
actually
- Wi-Fi so then you can scan Wi-Fi
signals and you can geolocate offer
those Wi-Fi signals and the cost of that
is very very low you plug a battery into
him and we all have those battery packs
that we can use to reboost our phones
and a device like that could potentially
run for a week off of a simple battery
so the Google Maps geolocation API offer
to four to four devices where if you
want to scan cell circuits if you want
to scan Wi-Fi and you want to get back a
latitude and a longitude so we'll take a
look about how it works like I said it
uses Wi-Fi and cell signals so the
Raspberry Pi and this guy runs Linux and
if you're using Linux you can there's a
command as a shell command that you can
call sudo wlan0 dev scan something like
that what what you can do like in Linux
there's a simple command where you can
scan for Wi-Fi and if you have like a
cell circuit in there there's an API
that you can use the scan for cell and
what that will do is it'll return a big
text block and that big text block has a
list of all the Wi-Fi towers that it
gets are all the Wi-Fi access points
that it can see and every Wi-Fi access
point has a unique identifier you're
probably familiar with a MAC address in
a network card an access point is a very
similar address it's sometimes called
the bssid but usually be SSID and MAC
addresses are used interchangeably so
you can get the bssid s of the Wi-Fi
access points around you and usually
when you do a scan like that you get a
signal strength back as well you've
probably noticed like when you open your
phone and you're looking for Wi-Fi or
you open your laptop and you're looking
for Wi-Fi there's a little visualization
of the signal strength usually 1 bar 2
bar are 3 bars and that signal strength
actually comes back as a decibel loss
and if you know the decibel loss or the
primary signal you can start looking at
how you can calculate the distance
between you and that access point and
then once you have all of this data then
you can call Google and you can call the
geolocation API with a simple HTTP call
that you pass it the data and I'll show
an example of that in a moment but you
pass it the data you pass it your API
key and it will return back some
location info and some accuracy
estimation around that it's not going to
be able to pinpoint you to the nearest
millimeter but what it will do is it
will give you a rough estimate for say I
think you're at this latitude and
longitude
and you're within 20 meters of it or
something along those lines so it works
like this so say you have your device
and what it will do what it does is like
it scans like I said each of the cell
towers are each of the Wi-Fi access
points around you and it figures out a
distance to them based on the signal
strength and that can be plugged into a
formula like this so this is the free
space path loss formula so what you did
what it is is it's a decibel value and
you know the decibel value upon scanning
cuz it will tell you the loss so it'll
be like something like negative a really
strong signal is about negative 30
decibels not great signals about minus
60 if you're below minus 60 you're
probably gonna be dropping off a Wi-Fi
if you're above minus 30 you're probably
sitting on top of the access point so so
a good strength a good strong signal
it's gonna be between negative 30 and
negative 60 decibels loss so you know
that value you know that decibel value
and you know the frequency which is F in
this formula because your Wi-Fi access
points gonna be operating on 2.4
gigahertz or it's gonna be operating on
5 gigahertz and you know K K is a
constant and it's there are a number of
different constants but it'll give you
32 point 4 4 is the constant you use if
you measure D in kilometers and if you
measure F in megahertz if you change
after gigahertz or change D to meters
then that constant would change but
there's a lookup table where you can
find them so in this case you know I've
been using 32.4 for is the constant so I
have K I have F and I have DB so that
will allow me to calculate D where D is
the distance between me and that access
point now what's the drawback for that
anybody know yeah I mean I know I'm 20
meters from the access point but that's
like I'm on a circle right with a radius
of 20 meters and I could be anywhere so
how do you think you'd get around that
triangulate with number of different
ones absolutely so let's take a look at
how that would happen so here I am with
my device and it's probably a little
inaccurate because I'm using a cell
phone that probably has a GPS but you'll
forgive me it's the best graphic I could
find so here I am with like my device
and I do a scan and I see these three
access points
from these three access points I can
establish a radius that I am from the
first access point I can establish a
radius that I am from the second access
point and I can establish a radius that
I am from the third access point now the
overlap of these three then gives me a
pretty good estimate for where I am at
this moment in time now this is nice
because if you're in a location where
there is a lot of access points then you
can you know the area of that overlap
will get smaller and smaller and smaller
and as a result you've got a better
estimate for your actual location now
there's a few drawbacks with this if the
eagle-eyed amongst you if I go back to
the formula might have noticed that it's
F SPL which is the free space path loss
now there's rarely free space between us
and access points so for example a 2.4
gigahertz signal you know what the
biggest absorber of 2.4 gigahertz
signals are to knock off your signal
strength water excellent yeah it's
actually water and what are you mostly
made of right so so my pro tip is a
Googler to use if you have a weak Wi-Fi
signal at home ask your family to lie
down on the floor and so they'll stop
blocking it and then you can get great
Wi-Fi but yeah like a 2.4 gigahertz
access point water so like if trees also
are made mostly of water so that that
can knock off the strength of it so
again the more of these actual access
points that you can scan the better and
as a results you know you can greatly
greatly reduce the size of the red
circle here okay so now once you've done
that this is the theory and how does it
actually all work in practice so if I'm
building an application and I scan the
access points near me then all I have to
do is build a JSON bundle like this one
with a list of my Wi-Fi access points I
list the MAC address of the access point
that I've scanned and I list the signal
strength of that and like I said the
commands like in Linux or an Android or
on Windows or on Mac when you issue
those commands to scan Wi-Fi they'll
give you back this data you also list
the signal-to-noise ratio you sometimes
get that you sometimes don't if you
don't get that just fill it in with a
zero and then you take this and then you
call the Google API with that and here's
our just an example of how you do it
using a curl you know so your curl you'd
give it in this case I'd stored those
values into a JSON file
then you pass that with the content-type
set to json up to google api's comm /
geolocation geolocate and then you give
it your api key and if you've ever done
any google maps development you'll see
there's an online console where you can
go to get an api key and just the api
key is what we use to know that it's you
that's calling it and not somebody else
using your key and you know in many
cases some services are billed and you
don't want other people using your
service so you have an api key for that
and you just do this call for using the
api key and you get back something like
this so in this case you know i got back
a latitude and a longitude and an
accuracy value and the accuracy value is
in meters so when i did this call based
on these two access points these were
well known access points I had a nice
signal off of them and I was able to get
back in accuracy that it said I was
somewhere about 20 meters from that spot
so I'm gonna do a little demo which
means I need to start up the robot and
he takes a few minutes to boot up so
just one second
so he takes a few minutes to boot up so
he's got a Linux operating system on
board and that needs to boot up and then
as I use VNC to shell into him what he's
getting a bit fussy I use VNC to shell
into him so well that's all booting up
I'm just gonna show a little bit of the
code that he actually uses so here he is
when I was building him on my desk at
home with his with his little friend
anybody recognize his friend here so on
him so because he's runs Linux
I used the programming language called
Python and I don't anybody familiar with
Python yeah a lot of hands good and
python is a really fun interesting
language too for doing something like
this because you know it's a very low
powered computer on his on board with
him so you know running an IDE or that
kind of thing would be very very slow
but if I build it in Python I can
literally shell into him from my laptop
I can change code on the fly I don't
need to compile it I know Python just
kind of sort of compile and then just do
some edits and off I go so in this case
the command at the top that you can see
here a pseudo ID IW w dev wlan0 scan is
the linux command that you use to scan
your Wi-Fi access points so at any
moment in time and you'll see what the
robot will do is he will draw
around whenever he hits a barrier he
moves to avoid that barrier but at the
point that he's moving to avoid the
barrier then he does a geolocation call
and what he's doing in that case is he's
issuing this command to Linux he's
getting the values back from Linux and
it's a big text blob from it and then
it's just as simple as using regular
expressions and never thought I would
say that expression but it's just as
simple as using a regular expression to
scan for the BSS so if you have a Linux
box and you issue that commands you'll
see in this big bunch of text the all of
the MAC address all of the Wi-Fi access
points near you including their BSS and
this is the regular expression that you
can use to just pluck that string for
the BSS out of the text blob and then
all I do is I just turn I create a list
of all my BSS is and that's the third
line of code and then for the signal and
the signal strength that I mentioned
it's really important for you to be able
to pass the signal strength up to
googles and then you know that was
plugged into the FS PL formula that we
saw earlier on so you can get back a
location the signal strength does come
as part of the return from a Linux call
and I just use a regular expression for
that create a list out of them and now
that I have these two lists I can create
that JSON blob that I spoke about so
when I have that JSON blob I can just
create a data item using Python and then
using the requests library in Python I
can post up to the geolocation API pass
my API key and get a value back and then
that value is going to give me my
geolocation all right this guy should be
booted up by now so let me sign in to
him I'm gonna put him on the stage over
here now you see where the stools were
laid there so that he doesn't drive off
the edge so I'm just opening up a
terminal so that I can sign in to him
and I can get him running just I gotta
put the mic down for a sec
and there he goes so he starts driving
oh he's trying to go off the stage until
he sees a barrier and then when he sees
a barrier he'll take a look around he
does a geolocation to say hey there's
something interesting here so you can do
an internal mapping of where he is so at
that point when he's looking around
looking left and right he doesn't have a
backup camera so he might back into
things you know so when he looks left
and right like that you know at that
point he's making the call up to Google
giving the scan of where he is right now
the Wi-Fi access points nearby and I can
do this and he gets a little sassy you
know doing a scan of like where he is
right now getting a location back and
then writing it to firebase you know I'm
gonna put him on the floor down here let
him drive around for a bit so and then
he would write his location to firebase
and then once it's in firebase now I can
start reading that data out of firebase
and like plot a map of where he's been
now one small drawback in demoing him in
a place like this can anybody think of
what it might be sometimes he gets a
little upset he goes in circles anybody
I did why would you think I would get a
really bad location on him being here
well the Wi-Fi it's actually really good
but it's also temporary these are
temporary hotspots like next 17 is just
set up for these last few days so it's a
so he gets a pretty bad signal because
of that so what I did and I'll show next
as I took him in a cab and we drove
around San Francisco and so I did that
location check with him in San Francisco
and here's some of those spots that he
was actually able to geolocate himself
to so if you know San Francisco pretty
well you'll see we right now are here
must go and center west so last night I
had him scan some locations I did not go
up this street but for some reason you
know the accuracy didn't show the
greatest it showed me within a certain
distance but I've been spending a lot of
time going up and down here and I'm
staying in a hotel over here somewhere
so you know by putting him in a car in
this case and having him periodically
called the geolocation API by
sniffing signals around him by sniffing
in this case its Wi-Fi signals around
him I was able to get a pretty accurate
look on where he is pretty cool right
now
what can you start doing with this kind
of data you can start turning it into
real intelligence in this case all I did
was I plotted it on a map that's kind of
nice but what if it was a much more
expensive much more important asset than
a simple data robot what if this was
like I don't know $100,000 truck or a
truck carrying a priceless cargo now
what if I want to geolocate that kind of
thing I could do that and I can plot it
on a map or I could timecode it in that
case in this case here you just saw I
put a bunch of pins on the map but what
if I time coded them then you could
actually tell the route that I was
taking was a heading north was a heading
south where was I in this location that
kind of thing so if it's a really
expensive really valuable cargo
I could start doing that kind of thing
with by getting a geo code getting a
lock on his environments and then when I
write it to a database and when I write
it to something like firebase it's
really really simple to do so I could
also write that with a time code so at
some point when I read it back it gets
pretty interesting now what if I have a
thousand of these and they're spread all
over the world now I can start really
turning data about how they're being
used into intelligence maybe there's
some cities in the world where I need to
have trucks where I don't have them and
there's some cities in the world where
I've got too many trucks and I can see
the routes that they're taking and how
they're mean how they're being used and
things like that so really really start
turning data into intelligence and
there's one partner of ours that they
have this really innovative solution and
I'll show a little bit more about them
in a moment
but what they do is they put a sensor
into garbage cans and here in the US
like I live up in the Seattle area and
for me my trash is collected every
Friday morning now it doesn't matter if
my bin is empty or if my bin is
overflowing it's still collected every
Friday morning and for example during
the summer you know when it's hot if the
bins have been filled on Tuesday and
they're not picked up until Friday they
can get a little bit stinky so what this
company has done is that they have
sensors that they put into bins and
these sensors when they fill up when the
bin is full it recognizes it at its fall
and the sensor dials home and says I
been at this location and I'm full so
the company instead of having a set of
trucks that have to go in fixed routes
you know in these areas on Monday these
areas on Tuesday what they can do is on
demand they can see the optimum route to
divert a truck to to pick up trash today
so the track that so the trash is picked
up at the time that the bin is filled
that's really clever
and that's really really cool and who
would have thought that being able to
put geolocation in a trash can could end
up being something that could make life
a little bit better for everybody and I
think that you know situations like that
and innovations like that are things
that are really really cool and when you
start broadening your mind about what
you can do when you can geolocate an
asset you can start coming up with
things like that it's not just about
tracking pets it's not just about
tracking trucks there are I mean there
are a thousand great solutions that
nobody's thought of yet and hopefully
the technology that we're building will
help you to do that
so going further there's a lot of api's
around geo that also make scenarios like
this possible so you've got the location
of something well so what how'd you get
there so we have like a there's a
distance matrix API and there is a roads
API and there's the geocoding API and
other ones here that will allow you for
example to determine if I'm at location
a and I need to get to location B what's
the optimal way of getting there if I'm
going right now it might be a lot faster
to go on the highway but if I'm going at
rush hour it might be a lot slower to go
on the highway scenario such as that one
it doesn't have to be the situation
right now you can actually print
pictures situation in the future and
we've put a lot of machine learning
intelligence into understanding distance
and directions so that you can calculate
optimum times to get from A to B does
the places API that I spoke about
earlier on so I don't know maybe there's
in a scenario like the the missing pet
one you might realize the missing pet is
in a pet store you know something along
those lines I don't know and hopefully
he's not being resold so and one of my
personal favorites is there's a roads
API and I think this one goes really
really nicely with the Wi-Fi cell based
geolocation because as I told you
earlier on there's a there's an element
of uncertainty you get back a latitude
and a longitude and you get a radius
where you might be but if you're
tracking an asset
for example a cargo that's on a truck
you know that's gonna be driving in a
road so if the center of that circle
isn't on a road with the roads API you
can actually snap to an actual road and
here's an example of like this is near
my house and I took Freddie out for a
drive last week and if you notice the
black line the end points of the line
segments of the black line like here and
here and up here are where geolocation
returned where it thought Freddie was
now I wasn't thankfully driving in my
neighbor's backyard at this point and so
what I did was I got all of those points
that were being plotted that were being
returned to me by the geolocation API
and I said look I know I'm driving on a
road
let me pass that to the roads API and in
the roads API gave me back the blue line
and as you can see the blue line it's
nap perfectly to the actual roads around
my neighborhood which I thought was
really really cool and but in this case
I didn't time code anything so you don't
know if I went that way and around and
up or if I went that way turned and ran
around this way so you know by time
coding points you could make it even
more intelligent but here just being
able to snap to roads so you know
instead of just me having fun driving
around my neighborhood again if you have
expensive assets being shipped somewhere
and these are being geo located off of a
cheap circuit you know you can then
start doing something like this to snap
to roads to get intelligent about where
they are right now where they're going
and things like that so then going
beyond this then thinking you know we're
here at the cloud conference and there's
lots of great tools for cloud and three
of these the first a known cloud data
lab so cloud data lab is all about
taking in big data and turning it into
visualizations so it's a suite of tools
that will allow you to do that so again
if you have many thousands of sensors
around the world gathering geolocation
data you've got big data right how do
you want to slice and dice that data how
do you want to turn that into
visualizations and the Cloud Data lab
the idea behind that is it gives you the
tools for that and then there's the
cloud machine learning api's so again if
you've got big data and you want to
identify patterns in that data for
example the trash truck scenario that I
was talking about you know you can start
beginning to understand by training a
model to say
I don't know for example trash cans in
this town tend to fill up quicker than
trash cans in that town or they fill up
quicker during the summer than they do
in the winter or in the post-christmas
period they tend to fill up really
quickly because everybody's putting like
the wrapping paper in the boxes and
things like that so those kind of
patterns can emerge from machine
learning and again you can start
training your systems to be far more
intelligent training them off of geo
data and being able to build better apps
and build better scenarios and maybe
even build better businesses and then
the third one is the vision API and if
you're at the keynote yesterday the
vision API is now able to detect things
in video as well as in photographs it
can detect sentiment and video and it
doesn't show here it's hiding behind
Freddie's bowtie but he's actually got a
little camera on his front and this is
like a ten dollar camera and so and it's
1080p so you know a device like that on
a simple computer with a camera on it
you could start recording video you can
Gio you can get a geo code location you
can tag where that video was filmed and
then using things like the vision API
you can then even determine what's in
that video when you're filming it again
lots of great scenarios you know to
build great businesses on and you know
I'm hoping that you know today I was
talking about the company that you know
picked up trash and that's in novo and
had this innovative thing for picking up
trash what will I be talking about next
year you know there may be some people
here listening to these talks
seeing what's possible with cloud and
coming up with great scenarios maybe
even somebody in this room today or
somebody who is at the keynote today and
yesterday and you know I'd love to hear
about how you're using these api's and
how you're building on these api's that
really really build innovative scenarios
and the CTO of a novo gave gave us this
quote you know just really talking about
as the world's population is increasing
and more waste is being generated then
it's really vital to make sure that
waste collection is as efficient as
possible and how more efficient can you
get then actually waste collection on
demand as opposed to the far more
primitive way that we have of you know
your trash is picked up in a particular
day then there's the company pod and
those are the guys that make this little
device that I spoke about and you know
this device it like it has Bluetooth
sensor it has Wi-Fi and it has a 2g cell
signal so if it's on the pet scholar and
the pet goes
missing it once you ping it it will dial
home over the 2g cell signal and it will
also use the 2g circuit to sniff towers
around it sniff Wi-Fi around it'll use
the ble to scan beacons around it and it
will determine a location from that and
dial home and then it will show up on
your app and you know I just got this
the other day so my dog isn't with me
but I've been playing with it if you
want to see some of the locations that
had detected me as being in because I
have it in my pocket I can show you on
my phone later it's pretty cool and
again you know I've had a dog now for
nearly 10 years and I used to go to
Radio Shack in the Apple Store and other
places like that all the time to see if
I could get a locator for my dog because
I don't want to lose him but they were
always like almost the size of a water
bottle now because of this kind of
technology they can fit in something as
big as this and then the last one is a
doctor in demand and again using
geolocation what doctor and demand have
done very very simple but very very
innovative is that we all have primary
doctors or GPS but you know how often is
it that we need to talk to our doctor
but we have to make an appointment with
them it's a little bit like the trash
pickup scenario that we have to go
according to a schedule we have to be
able to fit into something but if we
need a doctor on demand and there are a
bunch of doctors who don't have
appointments at this moment in time we
need to know where they are they need to
know where we are
so using geolocation this company doctor
and demand have been able to match
customers with doctors so that they can
be seen by a doctor far sooner than if
they had to wait on an appointment for a
specific doctor and particularly in
large healthcare organizations where
there's a centralized database of your
healthcare it's not like this doctor is
going to be totally unfamiliar with your
medical record you can actually go see a
doctor who's very familiar with your
medical record and you can see them
sooner rather than later
so again geolocation opened up a
scenario like this and this kind of
thing probably wasn't possible you know
even three or four or five years ago and
the senior software engineer of that was
saying a direct connection between maps
between geolocation and improving
patient care now what better reason
right to be able to work on technology
like this it inspires me every day I
love working on this technology than to
be able to read a quote like that a
direct connection between what you do
and improving care for people
proving people's lives and you know
that's what I'm all about that's what
we're trying to be all about with Google
trying to be all about hearing cloud you
know improve quality of your life give
you tools give you frameworks give you
ap is that you can build something that
will improve other people's lives
whether it be tracking their pet whether
we picking up their trash whether it be
connecting them with doctors so just
with that I just want to say thank you
for being here
[Music]
you